bonjour à tous on est à las vegas
aujourd'hui c'est le dernier jour
monsieur s'est terminée hier comme vous
l'avez dit on va se faire une faq à las
vegas
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
alors là on est en direct du césar
palace c'est le casino le plus mythique
de las vegas il ya céline gorie chante
ici
elton john qui est passé par la carrière
je vous passe un peu l'histoire pas par
contre là on a juste derrière moi les
machines à sous qui sont là là il ya
toutes les parties de poker gens qui
jouent à ta qui jouent à la roulette
enfin on est vraiment dans un endroit
mythique et je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être cool d'être ici pour faire
une faq
donc je me suis posé par terre au milieu
de nulle part
j'ai posé je vais vous montrer belga
j'ai posé directement l'appareil sur la
valise donc regarder
[Musique]
si vous voyez bien c'est un peu la rage
donc on va faire une vraie facture et là
je vous remercie déjà d'avoir été
nombreux pour la première fois qu merci
d'avoir poser toutes vos questions parce
que je pense que voilà effectivement
c'est sympa c'est la convivialité on
apprend davantage connaître aussi de ce
côté-là je suis super content de lire
vos commentaires voire un peu vos
réactions j'espère à côté d'un vous êtes
curieux de savoir un petit peu dans
toute l'histoire donc voilà je la
partage
super content donc merci de la mémoire
quelle est ta caméra alors ma caméra
c'est un gh5 de panasonic pendant
longtemps j'ai filmé avec un os mots
plus de dj hi pour les battus de smoke
plus c'était la flexibilité avec le g5
c'est génial le g15 pourquoi pour la
stabilisation cinq axes pour la
colorimétrie pour la vidéo c'est
vraiment un appareil qui est génial tu
écris sur quel site d'aviation alors
j'avais parlé dans mon post effectué que
j'écrivais pour un magazine d'aviation
c'est pas pour un si j'écris pour un
magazine pour la compagnie tout jet donc
j'écris des petites chroniques très
courte
j'aurais pris 5 je croise à un
trimestriel me semble-t-il laisse pas de
bêtises
j'écris régulièrement sims nouveau light
jet vous découvrirez sinon vous ai mis
un lien devrait pouvoir retrouver les
publications directement dans la
description
pourquoi tes cheveux sont gris ouais
c'est la génétique 1 c'est comme ça à
partir de 25 ans ça commence à blanchir
et la bombe âgées
ces 38 1 qu'est ce que tu veux c'est
comme ça c'est là je vais ptet pas le
choix quelle est ta marque préférée de
caméras aujourd'hui c'est le panasonic
un excellent boulot tu le h5 canon à d
excellents produits nikon sony très très
bon aussi mais là pour moi panasonic cd
best tu as fait quoi comme études étant
plus jeune
compliqué sortie du bac bac ico j'ai
fait une fac d'histoire pendant trois
semaines trois mois auprès fac d'anglais
je ne suis jamais allé et ensuite j'ai
fait une formation musiciens formation
formation musicale pour devenir un
musicien pro une formation qui durera un
an au bout de six mois j'ai fait un
stage en studio d'enregistrement
j'ai arrêté la formation j'étais
assistant studio je me suis formé
directement là bas pour apprendre leçon
faire du son et ensuite j'ai travaillé
en live j'ai bossé pour une grosse boîte
qui s'appelle gial events était la boîte
à sons avant et lyon
j'ai travaillé je fais pas mal de choses
bougent et au nigéria d'or j'ai fait une
vie où coulent sans nigeria stella j'ai
fait pas mal de choses différentes
j'ai bourlingué travailler sans trop de
versailles sonorisé prugnard enfin voilà
plein de trucs
voilà voilà un peu l'idée de ma
formation initiale est ce que tu as fait
comme études pour travailler en
l'high-tech aucune
c'est une passion après c'est de la
vidéo donc c'est de la vidéo que ce
ratage avec vous donc il ya aucune étude
par contre l'idée c'est quand même de se
renseigner de bien connaître
j'ai donc c'est une étude du quotidien
voilà c'est vraiment d'apprentissage
quotidien merci pour cette vidéo de
voyage tué deux suisses n'ont pas du
tout français mais janot reste de clem
montpetit comment la première évaluation
de chêne bientôt bientôt suis désolé que
les mash up à la bourre je rentre de las
vegas et on le fait directement sur la
deuxième chaîne d'ailleurs elle par la
deuxième chaîne ol stratégie youtube
le lien est ici plus à rien à la
description connais-tu la marque blood
diot si oui qu'en penses tu que je
connais pas du tout
quel est le smartphone de terreau aides
qui existent déjà et que penses tu de
l'avenir du smartphone on va se diriger
vers des plaques en verre
bon alors qu'elle et laisse mon
smartphone préférée du moment faut il y
en a plein qui plaisent
alors moi je suis chez apple je suis un
peu bloqué maintenant parce que j'ai
vraiment tout l'environnement apple
l'iphone disent je trouve plutôt pas mal
après j'aime beaucoup les samsung galaxy
note suisse où c'est vraiment un très
très beau produit que huawei sont aussi
d'excellents produits
après j'ai pas de modèles préférés tu
penses tout l'avenir du smartphone
oman dirigés d'une manière générale sur
la tech sont des produits dématérialisés
je pense qu'on aura plus de device comme
ça on va plus est peut-être sur dire et
des objets un peu plus doux airs et bold
de la montre plus des objets qu'ils vont
communiquer entre eux l on vient de
renaître à face comme ça bon peut-être
d'ici quinze vingt ans que vous savez
disparaître je sais pas encore on va
vraiment qu'avec les lunettes de réalité
augmentée on va avoir plus dire et comme
le disait you were even dont des habits
connectés peut-être sur des vêtements
peut-être je sais pas mais en tout cas
l'objet en lui-même on lui mène à mon
avis risque de disparaître et les
casques jbl tu les trouves comment
j'adore jbl je trouverai le général ils
ont une excellente qualité sonore lors
les castes et ce n'est pas tout essayé
j'en ai essayé quelques uns tout feu il
faut vraiment un excellent boulot avec
tous les appareils microsoft si oui
lequel j'adore les appareils microsoft
la gamme surface elle est énorme
pourquoi tu m'as pas emmener avec toi à
las vegas mais jetant des gardes la
terre vegas avec moi de qui tu aspires
tu pour faire tes vidéos cuisinette
stade pour le blog du magazine et stade
c'est la référence c'est effectivement
une personne qui m'inspire mais qui
inspire énormément de personnes y en a
plein d'autres pour la tête j'adore ce
marc marquez brandely j'adore énormément
de gros gros youtuber je suis beaucoup
de chaînes américaines parce que je
trouve que youtube aux états unis à un
niveau de maturité qui est différent de
celui en france alors qu'ils pas qu'en
france et pas mature mais on n'a pas
fait le même chemin
on n'est pas arrivés au même point ça va
évoluer énormément et je trouve qu'il a
énormément de chiffres de chaînes
américaines qui sont inspirantes et
j'adore aussi beaucoup de chaînes
françaises africa vraiment un énorme
boulot avec des chansons d'une énorme
qualité en france dont il ya énormément
de belles choses à suivre sur youtube en
règle générale parce que tu as samsung
comme nouveau téléphone à la place
d'apple oui très clairement le problème
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est que je
suis connecté
g
si 16 giga watts déjà macbook pro donc
si je prends un téléphone qui est notre
marque notamment samsung
je vais pas rester dans un environnement
qui libère optimisé donc c'est un peu ça
qui me bloque aujourd'hui mais ça me
saoule j'adore je vous dise notre ville
ce sera génial et avec les raisons qui
l'ont fait aussi un excellent boulot
j'attends de voir maintenant ce qui va
se passer avec le s9 à venir mais je
trouve que samsung a vraiment de très
bon appareil et avec lave les airs avec
les caméras 360 qui font vraiment un
environnement qui est génial pour les
créateurs
surtout ce que j'adore chez eux c'est la
qualité de leurs caméras pour les photos
et les vidéos c'est top quel smartphone
te fait rêver sur sur une hausse en 2018
on est début 2018 donc y en a pas on n'a
pas encore tout là toute l'offre
j'attends de voir vraiment ce trailer du
côté d'apple et je suis vraiment très
curieux sur ses futurs hypothétiques
appareils des écrans pliables ça c'est
vraiment le truc qui fait réel et
soutient les 500 euros tu as très quoi
500 euros 500 euros j'ai fais quoi moi
je pense une week-end en amoureux et qui
m'accompagne voilà 500 euros c'est le
week-end sélectif pas forcément un
produit que penses tu du au nord 9 très
bon on a d'excellents god excellent
appareil c'est pourquoi monsieur heureux
bonne question
alors déjà mon nom commence par cher
donc c'est normal de m voilà ça me
paraissait logique
et puis comment comme mon fils est là il
fait tout petit il n'y a jamais fait un
recom tous les gamins lui c'est quoi
donc je crois y avait un sens par
rapport à mon nom je par rapport à mon
fils gros je trouvais ça cool
as tu d'autres passions exemple l'espace
te kiffe j'adore l'espace j'adore toutes
les chaînes scientifique d'ailleurs j'ai
un pote cas une excellente chaîne sur
l'espace et les connaissances on
s'appelle les démos d'un terrien aller
la découvrir parce qu'elle est vraiment
génial toutes les questions autour de la
physique la physique quantique ça me
passionne j'ai regardé des heures et des
heures vidéo et j'adore regarder parce
que je trouve que ça pose des questions
fondamentales sur notre place sur terre
voilà à prendre parce que vous avez des
questions ou tout de suite un peu
métaphysique mais je trouve ça vraiment
génial paul un peu pour cette faq en
direct du césar palace à las vegas merci
de l'avoir regardé je vous invite
d'assurer rester connecté à vous abonner
parce que j'ai énormément de contenu à
vous publiez encore sur césar palace va
y avoir d'autres voyages d'autres choses
donc dès qu'il aura des trucs un petit
peu sortent du commun tuque un petit peu
originaux on se fera dire effectué on va
partager
merci énormément à vous d'être là parce
que c'est génial ce partage avoir bon
retour vos commentaires vos questions ça
me permet de progresser d'avancer et que
je suis content parce qu'on apprend
davantage à se connaître même si on se
connaît pas directement en tout cas au
travers de vos interrogations portent
vos commentaires
tout un petit peu identifiée j'en
connais quelques uns parmi vous je suis
hyper content restez connectés puis
peut-être que quand on aura passé sapins
cap fête les cinquante mille attaque
laissant mis là on verra on serait et
pourquoi pas un espèce d'énorme pique
nique vendait tous ensemble un grand
meeting pour sa langue est pas encore
mais quand on sera encore plus nombreux
je pense organiser un truc offert
d'autres ce sera super cool merci à vous
je vous embrasse vous êtes les meilleurs
et là je vous laisse en direct de las
vegas avec le caesar palace
ciao
m
[Musique]